The joe rogan experience.
Oh,
nice.
Right.
I watched star wars today.
How was it?
I'm it.
It was like a Disney star wars movie.
Yeah.
Everything's super diversified.
The characters are all black and Asian women,
and there's women that are generals.
The women are running things.
It's like,
yeah,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
it's a game of Thrones.
It,
no,
no.
Ooh.
Little after the bell action there.
It just,
it was okay.
I was like,
get off as a fun movie.
It was fun,
but it was like,
it's like it got dignified.
It's like they just boiled all the bacteria off again,
Marxist Marxist file.
It's just,
it's just,
you know,
it's,
I don't,
I like a strong female character,
but I don't want to think that this is like a calculated move for you to create
a strong female care,
but it is capped because you want,
but I don't want to to notice that.
I know.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Somebody told me that about the black mirror somebody could play.
They said,
oh,
all the fucking heroes in this season's black mirror.
All women.
Like if you watch the black mirror and that's what you're concentrating on
Europe asshole.
Yeah.
Is that fucking shows amazing.
It's astonishing.
Nobody gives a fuck if does the lead or men who lead.
It's just a phenomenal,
shows me anxiety.
I want to turn it off halfway through mine.
I haven't seen this with me anymore.
I haven't seen the season though.
I haven't seen this seasons.
The greatest ever.
It's amazing.
Head metal,
heavy metal dog.
Crazy.
All right,
here we go.
Why don't you,
okay.